the title of our project is
bioinformatics pipeline to calculate the
frequency of sars code week 2 variants
of concern versus time and web
application visualization my name is
annabrit and i did go to mountain view
high school we worked alongside angelina
who goes to crystal springs at one
school
i'm angela i go to lindbergh high school
my name is lucian i go to college
my name is kira and i go to lexington
high school
and we worked alongside dr jepoliano
chavez
throughout the summer we studied single
nucleotide polymorphisms in the science
code between virus which often led to
the creation of new variants of concern
through our work we seek to understand
the viral evolution of science kobe 2
and its vocs over various geographic
regions using smp identification in
three step in silicon pipeline for
further application we also began the
development of the web application for
the business visualization of user input
sets of sequences
we looked at a total of 10 different
countries highlighted in the map shown
along with vowel strains from the
chinese rufus horseshoe bat and the
cinder pangolin from the 10 countries we
analyze data across three different time
periods july to the september of 2020
january to february of 2021 and march to
april 2021
choosing our data from a broad range of
locations and collection dates across
the globe enabled us to get a varied
sample set
by looking at the data of different time
ranges we were also able to see the
progression of the virus and its
virulence
we gathered our data from the global
initiative on sharing avian influenza
data or gives aid and used rstudio to
run code and generate the pipeline
specifically we ran all the sequences
through sam tools and bcf tools which
are used for variant calling and
converting the original data files into
vcf files
in general the pipeline has five main
steps indexing done through bwa
alignment identification of variance
through a comparison with the reference
file which is a sequence collected from
one of the first proven 19 patients
extraction
and calculation of frequencies from 27
specific mutations
when looking at a smaller subset of the
master spreadsheet certain smps show up
within the human gene code genome but
not within that of the bat or penguin 23
403 would likely have allowed it to make
the zoonotic jump as its position within
the gene encoding despite glycoprotein
is important in determining coast range
if we compare the heat map to the
phylogenetic tree we can see how the cat
how the vat and pangolin form their own
cluster and differs significantly from
the human genome as the values
progressed to march to april 2021 the
frequencies 23063 and 23603 which are
part of the mutations n501y and
p601h respectively significantly
increase over six times its original
value the mutations are responsible for
a greater resistance to antibodies which
would allow it to evade the immune
system smps 2 4 1 303 7 14408 and 23
403 stay relatively the same as they
play a large bowl and increase
transmissibility of the virus when
combined together
on another note we use the genome
browser called igv to visualize the vcf
files obtained from the pipeline
in the image to the left the gray lines
represent mutations therefore these also
sodium mutations are distributed across
an entire genome we are also able to
make comparisons between different time
periods
in the pictures to the right we create a
chronological comparison using mutation
n501y
and
sample files from brazil from july 2020
and january 2021
the red square is located in the
location of mutation n501y
we can see that in the samples from july
of 2020 none of them have that mutation
meanwhile in january of 2021 three out
of the seven files have the mutation
and we use this data along with other
further data to create the line chart in
the bottom which shows the frequency of
this mutation
since july 2020 to april 2021. as we can
see the mutation has continued to
increase and we can predict that right
now it's even at a higher percent
also we used a software called paimo
which is a protein model modeling
software to create an analysis of the
crcov2 spike protein
in the picture to the left you can see
that
we modeled the spike protein
a part signifies the receptor by knee
domain while the blue part signifies the
n-terminus domain
in the part of the result we have two
images image a does not include the
n501y mutation while image b does
from this images we can conclude that
the mutation the increased number of
polar interactions or hydrogen bonds
which increases the affinity between the
spike protein and the ac2 receptor in
the cell this indicates that
transmittability could potentially be
increased
also it is important to note that this
mutation is found in variants from the
uk south africa and brazil
in the meantime we also worked on
developing a web application to
visualize our results we use language r
and the library shiny to streamline the
process the basic code structure is
shown on the slide
so for our app we accepted user input of
past e
files
and we created frequency tables and
phylogenetic trees so the frequency
table shows the first 10 positions the
sequence that has been aligned through
multiple sequence alignment and it shows
the number of sequences that have each
nucleotide or amino acid at each
position
so we used sequence data from the source
code genome as well as the protein
sequence from the
spike protein specifically and for a
vital phylogenetic tree we used the
neighbor joining technique in order to
increase the speed at
which the web app functions this app is
still currently
in development and the data we used was
mostly for demonstration purposes
with higher frequencies of mutations it
leads to greater changes in
transmissibility and vigorous the
overall trend was that as time
progressed and the virus spread the
genetic variation increased leading to
greater separation among the countries
one commonality that we found was that
the smps which had higher frequencies
tended to affect the spike proteins and
in doing so it helps the virus to be
able to bind more effectively to the ace
to receptors on the cell itself
in terms of user future research we have
one concrete idea for the web app that
is to connect it with the data from the
pipeline
and create a line graph so that the
frequency of variance can be monitored
over time and health policymakers will
be able to use this information to
better guide
future actions against the pandemic
more generally we'd like to continue
tracking the evolution of cyrus for v2
various as data from around the world
continues to be collected throughout
this pandemic
more specifically we'd explore various
mutations and their impact on viral
abilities
such as zoonosis properties
finally we will streamline the data
analysis process for the future in
preparation for possible pandemics
thank you